well now we're gonna get into funny
funny so everybody knows everybody in
the 40 minutes because this podcast is
like pulp fiction oh yeah
that's what's great about it you know we
do here then we go to a side story we go
to here here and it all comes back
around so what is wool yeah more like
reservoir more like a reservoir dogs' a
little more a little piece of [ __ ] on
I'm tell you something when I was on mad
and they were looking for a latino guy
he had to pull for me I seem to remember
me pulling for you Bobby Bobby pulled
for me for about five years and they
they didn't want anything to do with me
and they went through everybody else and
they didn't like anybody else what names
are gonna be left out on this one but
they went through everybody else
auditioned you remember that yeah
everybody else audition yeah and then
finally it comes to that year and then
Bobby's like I told you about this guy
five years ago and then David so he goes
oh let's take a look at him but every
man what does he say after that every
time we had a table meeting or somebody
tape he table read or meet he'd go well
I finally got my Latin guy should have
listened to Bobby five years yeah and
then they cancelled the next season I
got to I got say it best Bobby what did
you say you got [ __ ] I got [ __ ] I'll
tell you why Johnny got [ __ ] is Johnny
got on to MADtv
at the last two years of it which they
cut funding right they weren't I mean
they were out this is remember do you
remember the last season they go it was
already bad enough to budget the budget
funding and all that was bad enough on
on the thirteenth season 14 remember
they would go hey look about the takes
each tank right there you go
I mean we'd like to have it in one but
we have to have it in two oh my gosh the
press and this when he was on it early
how many takes did you guys used to do
in front of my authority so I mean they
just kept on going and going and going
and they were to the point where like
we've got to shoot once or so every way
now the answer of like you can you don't
want to flood your lines you don't want
oh now that takes you kind of out of the
moment and whatever but yeah I came in
if ifs ultimate salzman had to listen to
you oh by the way whisper out Davis
Halsman
was breathless breath um can we go back
to funniest funny or not anyway I just
worked with him I'll tell you about the
who David yeah he's a great guy he is I
do love him he's great meet you he's a
good boss he's still great he was still
great to work with uh so funny is funny
they all know our sets they know exactly
what we're gonna be doing matter of fact
freddie was one of the riders on it so
Freddie knew everybody sets on top of it
oh yeah so what basically they were
doing was they don't want the host to
step on anybody's material well you know
the shows are going so they they tell
him so I was talking about this so so
Carlos was hosting and they knew that I
was I think I was last on there myself
really
you were really late on the show yeah
yeah and I at that time I had this my
closer like this killer closer bit
called parking in my parking one of the
best jokes ever heard that was it was a
about a it was literally five minutes
long and he's about this Persian Persian
guy who was screaming at everybody
because someone was parked behind his
car and he was just screaming out who's
spotting in my body from a different
person he was calling the apartment
intercom you know the intercom people
didn't even know who's calling I mean
hello he is he should parking in my
[ __ ] parking who's parking in my
pocket it was my closer bed I just saw
really it would do destroy destroy the
room destroy and this was early dude
this is again remember this is mid late
90s where this is pre 9/11 this is I
mean people and stuff like that was just
fun and fodder forever it was great so
Carlos knows this so in between the the
the transition that I'm gonna be on the
next row there was two of us on the next
show so they're gonna bring up this one
guy or whatever so he in between they're
gonna bring up did they bring up the
first guy and then I don't think if I
can remember dude remember where he did
it but basically I'm up I'm up next and
he decides to do this bit on
Rach yeah the Iraq war and he goes into
this law and first of all everybody's
like remember Pat buckles comes running
goes the [ __ ] is he doing because that
wasn't anything that you've written so
they really knew but he does what three
four minutes on yeah I know you could
have been here too my friend no [ __ ] you
my friend but so he's wearing this
accent out oh now I know what the [ __ ]
he's doing we all know what the [ __ ]
he's doing but he played like he didn't
know oh right
[ __ ] Johnny's got that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
I wasn't even gonna go on [ __ ] it oh you
really live it that's how I was like I'm
just gonna leave right now that the
matter was in front I was like I just
get ready to walk out I said [ __ ] it
so they said okay here's what he's gonna
go up to the audience and he's gonna
explain it to them so this was I don't
even know if this made it better or were
they made it worse slightly in between
he goes hey look dude look [ __ ]
so that bit that I just did the dude
coming up next has something similar to
what I was doing similar to what you
were doing yeah you kidding me yeah you
know I got that bit for you yeah I'm it
worse laughs so then the art so he goes
so so just laugh you know give it up you
know don't think about [ __ ] me and I
[ __ ] alright it's crazy
anyway no it's crazy that's the story
yeah and then and then now you know why
wouldn't have gone on the road after
that anyway yeah cuz I got asked by him
after that anyway so you know I still do
believe that it might have helped you
mm-hm to go on the road with him but
probably what I've did but you you know
have certain principles and ethics um
but you're right but but you can't have
too much pride though prides bad prides
not gay not so I can I can [ __ ] things
up for you Matt's why I'm going to
Montreal because um
for years I've said on podcasts probably
a thousand of them for years
Montreal doesn't like me I've never been
invited they hate me this and that right
but then what happened was the last
three or four years they've been asking
but
still on podcast I'd be like [ __ ] them
they hit me right when they're inviting
me right so one day I was at the Comedy
Store
and um one guy from Montreal was talking
to me in the parking lot and I got not
this year man or whatever and he walks
away and Howie Mandel was there and he
was like what was that about because I'm
going to Montreal I got and I told him
they haven't never invited me and now
they are and he said you should never
make decisions based on resentment
especially in this business you should
do mom that's a that's that's actually
really good right and so I go the next
in the house I said yes which was this
year so you're going and when a couple
weeks yeah yeah oh wow
now which shows are you doing I'm
hosting the dirty shows and then I'm
also doing a couple of like a gala and
they're televised thing but I'm doing it
okay but it's yeah but that's the same
thing it's like we have these as
stand-ups these little resentments and
like a list I don't know if you but I
have a list in my pocket of guys that
have [ __ ] me
yeah well guys I said things Rio man and
then you try to lash out in your own way
and it's not healthy it never been works
out you never feel better about it right
yeah so I'm trying to let go now you
know when you're there though you got it
and try to enjoy it and don't get you
know don't get Bobby while you're there
yeah you know what I mean like with your
shows you know how you get what do you
you know you're gonna be doing these
shows don't start going you know don't
start doing all that why is it when you
didn't pressure me you you used to do
the smoking thing to like I used to
smoke a lot alright yeah he used to
crouch down yes oh wow yeah I'm not
standing Raya Raya Raya Raya yeah I
really sound like that to you yeah yeah
you sound like that from everybody right
is that pretty close that's pretty good
yeah yeah by the way speaking of that
one time Paul I have was having a
conversation with Paul Rodriguez Oh
their senior there's a fun time not
cheers fun Club right there you like the
skateboarder nah you know too because he
became you know pretty big with
the young people but he said the same
thing one said we were talking I was
like yeah man and if I hit big I'm like
I'm not doing this club or that club or
because he treated me shitty and they
wouldn't put and then he's like nah you
know and then he was like do the
opposite he said he did the opposite he
goes he goes you know when I got my
break I went in Dhahran I charged fifty
thousand yeah he said he always extra
charged the clubs that were shitty to
him or didn't book him before
[Music]